Indian Prime Minister Narendra Modi says
his country is hurt and angry following
Monday's border clash with Chinese
troops in which at least 20 Indian
soldiers were killed each side blames
the other for the violence the deadliest
clash in the disputed Himalayan border
region in four decades the Prime
Minister has warned he's given the
Indian Army free rein to respond to any
new aggression from China saying goodbye
to a father family members and the
community attend the funeral of Satnam
Singh the Indian soldier was one of at
least 20 who died in violent clashes
with Chinese soldiers in the disputed
Goguen Valley on Monday Indian Prime
Minister Narendra Modi says no territory
was lost in the incident and warned of
his military's capabilities XM Hall
whether it be action or counter action
our armed forces are doing what is
necessary for the security of the nation
on land in air and on water the country
today has such capability that no one
can even dare look towards an inch of
our land the fight erupted in a region
of the Himalayas where an exact border
has never been defined both sides have
accused each other of intruding into
their territory provoking the incident
China has acknowledged that its forces
suffered casualties but has not released
any figures the two sides are currently
engaged in dialogue to resolve the
issues on the ground through diplomatic
and military channels I have nothing to
offer anger has now spread across India
sparking protests calling for a boycott
of Chinese goods we are calling for the
Chinese president to be hanged the
Chinese army brutally killed our troops
our movement will continue to protest
and demand that consumers shun all
Chinese products sold in our country
experts say while the two nuclear-armed
neighbors are unlikely to head to war
he's in tension in the region his
essential as cross over to DW
correspondent Nimisha is while in India
and correspondent Matias billing it and
Beijing nimisha I'd like to start with
you Prime Minister Narendra Modi is
warning China and people in India seem
really angry is that the overall feeling
across the country
well Rebekkah there definitely is anger
and resentment against the Chinese which
had been building over the last six
weeks given the tensions along this
deepak to water the line of actual
control and the deaths of Indian
soldiers has really brought matters to a
head well it is important to point out
that the more extreme protests which we
have seen are being held by troops
perhaps to represent a wider sentiment
in India especially to hit China where
it hurts
which is in terms of economic ties of
trade association for example has called
for a ban on Chinese goods and perhaps
most concerning there are reports
surfacing of India's telecom ministry
and real amnesty perhaps rolling back on
China over 80 billion dollars and this
is something which can hurt India more
than China right Matias I'll turn to you
now
we heard that that Modi has threatened
to use whatever force necessary to sort
of hit back to China what are the
reactions there in China from that
morning yeah the Chinese diplomats have
as always been quite vocal in in what
they said they've amassed to China India
to discipline its military but here
inside the country the tone is quite low
it's the conflict is almost absent from
the news here in China and to me that
looks like China is really trying not to
fan the
nationalist sentiment that is easy to
stir up here in the country in order to
have more options China's diplomats are
also constantly reiterating that they
are in dialogue with India and they are
trying to solve this diplomatically so
at the moment they are definitely not
playing the nationalist card as they
have been in other conflicts
nimisha what does this mean for the
future of this very long-standing border
dispute the rules of engagement that
govern this border dispute and the way
the two sides conduct themselves there
have been confidence-building measures
which dictate that arms not be used
along the border which is what made
these do these deaths all the more
shocking now there are there are reports
coming out that perhaps India's military
can perhaps reconsider these rules of
engagement there is also a need from the
Indian side to hold a really strong
stance against China what it perceives
of China's aggression of China denies
this incident to the Chinese side but
Indians denied this as well and to say
they will ensure that no land grabs take
place by China let me should have strong
in Delhi and myth he is pulling an
impatient thank you very much